why do you think atheists are so hated
I've seen poll after poll and we've
talked about them and some other shows
that atheists are the most distrusted
group in America people would never vote
for an atheist to be President you know
Barney Frank who came who was a
congressman from Massachusetts a pretty
liberal place came out as gay and
something like 1983 didn't come out as
an atheist until he was on Real Time
with Bill Maher after he had retired and
since then has even backtrack a little
bit on saying that he was an atheist
what is it about atheists because the
Atheist that I know are pretty much by
and large the most decent sort of
humanistic open people yeah that I know
and yet there's this portrayal of them
that's completely the reverse I don't
think it's that people think that
atheists have like horns or anything you
know I think there's there's racism and
there's xenophobia and there's hate and
there's fear and there's all of the
different things that feed into why
people don't trust or don't like what
they don't understand I think
specifically though with atheists you
have to put yourself in the shoes of the
religious to understand where this
hatred comes from because of course
non-religious people don't have any
problem with religious people running
for often office it's religious people
right I'm sorry non-religious people
don't have any problem with atheist
running for office it's religious people
that have a problem with that and think
about okay so for example you're an
upstanding gay man and there are though
I have my moments do you every moment
and there are some religious people who
think that you are just Yeah right who
think that like like being gay is
disgusting like Edward Fallon's book
because that's what the Bible teaches
and so they have these ideas in their
head that your lifestyle is an
abomination and blah blah blah and it is
a choice and you could have chosen to
live another way but you're still a
person and you're a flawed person and
you've made a difficult choice and maybe
you can come back around I think that
there's something that really speaks to
the core of the structure of belief that
an atheist is somebody who actively
rejects the foundation of what matters
to these people yeah and
and that act is so closely tied to what
they think of as the devil what they
think of as evil what they think of as
you know heresy
all of these pure just irrationally
fearful States its apostasy it's it's
what fuels Isis right it's it's worse
than being an Islamic apostate it's
worse than being a Christian apostate
it's being an atheist right it's the
ultimate it's the ultimate apostasy and
I think that that's really where it
comes from and because of that
historically generation after generation
I think we get a bad rap so you've got
some people who are such deep believers
that there's no way they're gonna come
around you and then you've got other
people who just equate the word atheism
yeah with like I don't know just like
bad stuff like they're criminals they're
they're just like bad dude right so I
want to get to New Atheism yeah but do
you think the other piece of this is
that to me it seems like because an
atheist can come from any religious
background be any sex be any sexuality
be any nationality all those things that
in a weird way what they fear is that
this group of people is coming together
using sort of the best of all of us you
know you mean like they like that they
think that it's sort of like for gay
people there are gay people of every
nationality and ethnicity and religion
and all that and that's why there's so
much richness I think in the gay
community and I'm starting to think that
that's what people fear about atheists
too because there's lacking of these
white atheists but see this is something
that I think intrinsic and what you just
said the gay community like the Atheist
community it exists it's not all right
yeah it exists but not to the same
extent because I think there's something
that's sort of fundamental to being an
atheist that makes some people reject
trying to find community sure the whole
point is that we're not a church the
whole point is that we just don't
believe it's not that we all believe the
same thing is that we have a lack of
belief and I think that by definition
that makes some people feel like we
don't need to band together right there
is no common thread here it's just the
default state all right so that's
exactly where I wanted to go with this
because new atheist that seems to be the
new thing so do you have a definition
for new atheist I can I can sort of tell
you what I think but I don't know
I mean I think that new atheist is a
term that's often used by non new
atheists so it's sort of a derogatory
term so I'm not really sure how to
define it because it seems like from the
outside people apply that label
who knows maybe I'm a new atheist I
don't know I do know that the term
firebrand atheist is one that's actually
kind of welcome within that community so
david silverman who is the president of
American Atheists he has a new book
coming out actually wrote the foreword
to his book which is really funny
because he's a hardcore firebrand
atheist and I'm like not at all
but I like that he is one because I
think it takes all types right and I go
by firebrand oh you mean like really
outspoken
oh yeah like he doesn't think you can be
an atheist Jew right like he thinks you
need to drop the Jew side because how
can you be both an atheist and a Jew you
have to you know hold on to your atheist
values and you have to be very open
about it like we talked about this at
length on my podcast
and I'm like of course you can be an if
he needs Sam Harris last week who's the
one of the biggest atheist I know that
that barely makes any sense but yeah he
goes so atheist right so it doesn't
believe in God but yeah I mean one of my
best friends is an atheist year when I
get it like and he's super Jewish I'm
super atheist yeah um and so I'm not a
firebrand atheist I am really kind of
accepting of people's religious beliefs
and I think that we need a spectrum of
more secular values if we want to move
the goalposts but I think it's important
that there are firebrand atheists the
same way that I think that it's
important that when you look at feminism
that there are men who hold on to
feminist ideals that there are women who
are out loud and proud and in front of
the line talking about it and then there
are women who act in a feminist way but
who don't make it their mission to
always you know be that feminist same
thing with black lives matter across the
spectrum you need the people that are
out in front that are that are being
loud that are making sure that people
pay attention to this movement but you
also need the people who quietly live
their lives that way everyday it's
almost like we should have a broad
spectrum of people there have been
different things and can all still get
along and exactly after this if you have
atheists of all these different flavors
then I think that you're going to see
more people being affected more people
that are afraid to come out saying that
person is just like me or I see
myself in that person and I can look at
them as a role model if we were all one
flavor we would turn off a huge section
of the population and I think to sort of
wrap this up I think that's sort of the
people that and I unfortunately happens
to be a lot of people on the left that
have been attacking new atheist my
friend kuklinski said that a new atheist
to him is just an atheist that finally
is saying I'm an atheist because atheist
used to have to just not say anything
that's true and when I see these people
on the left attacking new atheists as if
new atheists have some set of beliefs
all they have is this one thing in
common which is not belief not not a
bigger set and I you know I remember
dating somebody previously who I think
was a little confused about my atheism
but it was probably agnostic himself and
I remember him saying something about
like I just don't understand why you
have to be so public about it I don't
understand it's a private matter why are
yours and it's such a double standard
he's like are you kidding me religious
people are like the most public people
about their religion and the fact that I
want to say vocally I'm an atheist I
don't believe in God I don't factor God
into my decision-making I don't believe
in any afterlife I don't believe in
anything supernatural I'm a
science-based evidence-based thinker the
reason I do that is because then if I
continue to live my life the way that I
hope I'm living it in a moral way in an
upstanding way then people can look and
go oh that's what an atheist looks like
Oh
you